here we go here we go get ready we're
playing for stakes here stakes here
comes another big beast here's the big
bad wolf oh oh he's giving me beating
after beating right here okay what do we
got
crowns crowns everybody's out for the
crowns one minute wars on rated 32
players currently average rating 2082
time is the handicap time will be
adjusted according to ratings experience
level 50 tournament start take a deep
breath let's go let's get off to a good
start
come on fisherman oh push him around
push them around Oh what's what's the UM
what's going on here
whoa get in c-five the golfer might
throw here check get the light squared
bishop chop stop g4 I must now slip that
one let's go they're moving really fast
queenside castle get my king here before
it's too late
whoa what's their King doing right here
trade a bunch of times on the rook
they're gonna think I take with the rook
watch nope well I got the rook though I
got the rookie I got the rookie trade
the Queenie's trade the Queenie's march
upon march upon a pond a pond a pond I
got the d6 pawn to but I'm gonna target
it again they're defending but there
goes my epon he's really fast he's
really fast that a pawn run any pond
turn on a check just for fun
run a pond run a pond
Chapa bishop push up on get your rook
active check pin the night and then take
here its take and then Queen there was
probably something cleaner but I'm gonna
go with this i'ma have an edge on time I
better not fall for any cheap tricks
here oh I'm finally for tricks hang on
hang on check let's get this guy and
then haw man let's get this pun Wow
I had to win like I have to win like
this actually let's make sure I get the
W throw some checks in time burner time
burner time burner look back to
tournament oh I didn't mean to click on
that back to tournament there we go
for somebody is for a bunch of two's I'm
one of the twos man it can't be easy it
just can't be easy can it everything has
to be a struggle right there can't be
just any quick kills can we just have a
quick kill here back it up here we go I
think we've played this before this guy
and I this guy and I quick Quaid trains
trade Queens Oh being silly being silly
hit that pun good versus bad bishop good
versus bad bishop good versus bad bishop
here we go we have a grip we have a big
grip on the light squares it's not by
chance it's not by chance that this is
happening oh here we go
chop get out of pins trader rook or -
bishop here check it's coming pawns on
light squares pawns on light knights on
light rook good pivot about look up and
over
rook up and then over up and over not so
fast my King needs to do something else
he's stupid right there
they want to draw and I don't Oh
the bishop oh here we go now we're gonna
make progress progress progress King
position rook position flounder flounder
I had a flounder at that one what am i
doing take check time burners I'm on the
rook Oh sneaky sneaky how much time did
I have time no time check primo primo
pretty move take a bishop back to
tournament eleven six six six four two
bunch of two's here we go twenty-five
tick tick tick tick tick Oh sneaky
sneaky sneaky sneaky caro-kann fantasy
fantasy variation 'if I've needed 'if
I've needed 'if I've is played pin let's
push I don't know if that's right though
I was stupid okay am i getting crazy you
know if I'm in a pen I gotta get out of
the pin Oh trouble trouble trouble
trouble
let's put pressure on it back on it here
oh boy this is trouble I'm back on that
pond I can't even take it
oh this is bad here I gotta get out of a
pin I got a cadet I have to get out of
this pin check get that beep on hit the
Queen they could get my rook that's
alright I have this let's just wait oh
no is it me Oh hold there on my rook
there was Queen takes rook oh I was
really scared right there did you hear
my voice that was scared voice that was
the scared voice I was scared right
there let's take the knight chop him up
I'm on em seven pile-up on f7 get the
weakest link that guy was the weakest
link mates and stuff checks checks hit a
bishop chase it around
I'm really scared Bishop back no I'm not
scared rook here and pound here I mean
you know what I mean
Bishop check lead to me quickly check
check
oh is this close to me check one of
these rooks has to do it you could do it
rooks
well back to tournament they resigned I
think there was more resistance somehow
twenty twelve twelve twelve eleven we
I'm having nightmares against this guy
nightmares this guy plays really fast
can I catch him in a pre move we oh
we've played this before and I I thought
I had him but he weaseled out of the air
that was a bad joke that's what he
called bad joke just play chess quit it
with your jokes okay take this guy and
secure f5 this guy plays so quick he
doesn't give me time to think
give me time to think get over here
come on get c4 I gotta get this guy chop
there we go it has to be uncomfortable
it has to be uncomfortable right Oh get
nervous are they getting nervous look up
alright there's a pin there's a pin
there's the rooks are protected oh
they're running scared now they're
running scared check check oh look out
I'm feeling it I'm feeling here oh
there's a check check check
oh no come on you can do this take the
knight and then I had mate mrs. Mayton
won - I got it we went oh we went out
finally this guy gave me so many
beatings okay here we go
he for for the win here I don't know I'm
fumbling again with my words
fumbling fumbling with those words Grand
Prix Grand Prix
and pre-chopped a knight run away
recapture get out of pins here we go
here we go here we go here we go
move move why aren't you moving push
your puns push your puns get out of get
out of those same diagonals chop f6 f6
is a killer it's a killer it's a killer
queen g4 oh boy you could do it you
could do it you could do it get there
what are you doing oh we got made
threats tricky mates tricky mates H 5 H
5 H 5 tricky mates oh man tricky tricky
tricky back to tournament thirty thirty
thirty eighteen twelve ten oh here we go
eqi's eqi's chop this guy no let's do
this and then get g6 in Bishop g7 oh oh
now that is sneaky that is what you call
a sneaky move there's probably something
that I miss played there ah man okay I
shouldn't have they should have played
h4 maybe that's brutal that night is
gonna be a giant pain a giant pain is
that night gonna be oh boy okay I'm I
don't know what I'm doing here I don't
know what I'm doing run away fast just
run away what am i doing what oh man run
defend defend and run please hit the
Queen oh boy
Oh hold man Knight takes here something
bad is happening something bad is
happening can I get me mm-hmm I gotta
come here my bishop needs to play here
run King
Oh scary it's very scary don't
everything defended I'm somehow
defending somehow defending chop that
guy up
get my knight here get my bishop out and
everything is okay not so fast
I'm on that pond oh I shouldn't get that
night out of there oh man I'm gonna take
this pond if it pushes he's got to go
can that deal with that guy can that
deal with that guy bishop can't be
defended check no yeah block okay let's
get here my other up doing something
activity I need activity it--if t he hit
the rook and then do what oh there's a
fork there's a fork there's a fork
there's a fork there's a killer fork in
between ER oh man I don't have anything
how much time how much time how much
time I don't have any time ah ah I'm
beat there's check and then there's me
oh I'm be back - why did I have to lose
that one I was under so much pressure
that whole game I had that pawn on e4
earlier - crap okay I've lost three
before and I could maybe muster a third
place still or can I still hope for what
can I still hope for you know what
fishing-pole quick wins fishing pole
style
no no no no no no that's not happening
I'll get that night I'll be later get
out of there night let's come here and
then defend there might be rook takes
night in some variations I want to get
to e5 oh that bothers me
I thought I had a good position actually
after I kind of weaseled out after I
weaseled out did I have a good position
oh okay I'm gonna chop I should maybe
should taking this guy first
okay put pressure on this f4 or h4 first
if I do this the night gets to sit on e4
I mean that's all right what's no h4 if
anything what am i doing
let's go here watch over g3 I don't that
and I get in there let's take care first
and Shay's that night away get away
night get away okay
mmm here we got what do we got what do
we got defend upon get out of tricks ah
ah what am i doing hit this pod rook
takes pawn they're gonna miss it they
missed it Oh Oh sneaky sneaky come on
King save the day save the day King save
the day oh stop that pot he's quick he's
got fast legs that D pun run push up on
come back here defend push your Jeep on
h4 is probably good they don't have a
time though here give a check take a pun
one of the two back to tournament forty
seventy two fifty four forty two forty
forty here we go
Tao Tao tie Oh quick resign oh I gotta
stop with these things okay
oh okay well we're not entering um let
me let me get in d5 okay let's get in d5
and then do what okay let's get active
get these pieces out got a majority and
dark squared Bishop g3 g3 on the rook
I'm gonna keep my knight there for just
a bit just a bit Castle f6 open up the
position take the bishop now open it up
I have the bishop pair here we go here
we go here we go chop there in a pin I
get chop no matter what push the night
away remove the defender I should have
done this should have kept the Queen's
on the board oh they're trying for train
for me they're going after my king that
and I can't do anything great let's give
a check centralize my knight hit the
Queen sack here recapture like this and
then seems just too appealing let's go
for it
I want to crash through and get at that
King still I want to do it I want to
break through I'm on the bishop now and
I'm on f2 after it I'm on f3 if they
don't take my light square bishop I wish
time do they have not much on the bishop
f2 check this is really close to me I
don't want to end up in mate though oh
wait a second clean here I could take
here and I'm Reed I'm on this actually
Queen right here is strong oh I might
have to double rooks might have to
double rooks or actually rip back right
back here and I'm on g4 Queen takes I
get the Queen back if I move my bishop
I'm in mate don't move the bishop don't
move that bishop whatever you do don't
move the bishop don't move the bishop
don't move the bishop okay oh good job
don't move that Bishop rook takes part
either pond let's create a flight square
at the very least we need flight squares
flight squares take upon take upon and
then come back here just to defend
throwing some checks maybe some checks
or a pin grab this rook
and then throw in another check King up
get out of a check actually pawn push
would have been nice right here they're
still in the pen how much time do they
have right here is a safe square no
matter what move they make me just any
move back to tournament oh oh there's
nothing against my king okay back 90 70
70 56 54 oh man I need to get at least
70 Jake is running away with it what's
90 Wow okay here we go
13 in change here 13 and change this is
tight this is tight this is tight come
on let's go pair me out pair me up I'm
not getting quick wins could I get a
quick win okay
Grand Prix couldn't turn into quick win
here we go they're in between it come on
I'm up a piece come up a piece resign
love the piece just resign dark squares
I'm up two pieces you definitely want to
resign now right that's not to say
because I went all the time you're down
three pieces you'd certainly want to
resign right come on what's going on
here these guys to be me get my dark
square Bishop check what's going on here
check come on you know this is me no
this is me
take care checkmate soon take a pun I'm
on the Queen actually this is turning
out to be me checkmate just move don't
let that clock tick okay back to turnip
that was pretty quick 110 eighty eight
seventy two seventy seventy okay
there's gonna be some tough games right
down to the wire here I could feel it
there's a lot of people that are up
there battling for those crowns battling
for the crowns move your pieces already
move your pieces let's get this in okay
height squares it's Castle I almost
smell slipped on that one
oh my nights hanging it's a hanging
night a night it's chopped they have a
giant pawn center right here
giant pawn Center what am I doing with
that move I want to get to G 4G 4G 4G
form let's get out of a pin d5 let's try
e5 hopefully it works
my queen is unprotected okay let's do oh
I'm on my bishop up [ __ ] up twice my
knight on g4 if we go backwards what are
you doing that night could go backwards
ah okay throw in a check can I chase
that night away chase that night away
somehow come on chase that night away
this is away oh oh oh they must be
scared oh no what am i doing that's okay
maybe this works no it doesn't check oh
I hadn't I hear I'm missing things check
ah how many times are we gonna miss good
moves Forks finally make a good move
make a good move finally attack a knight
and grab upon resignation resignation
check trade Knights checks grab a pawn
grab the other pawn soon check back here
more checks
grab a knight grab a knight just take
just oh they're giving me check here
okay now we got it now I got it just
move quick move quick move quick move
quick give a check
come here stepladder here we go no
stalemate thank you back to tournament
88 130 is not gonna be K however maybe
there's something to be said for the top
three still please
that's still within reach French French
Queen trap can we get a queen trap no
they're not having any of it none of it
is happening okay that was a dummy move
why did I play my bishop there why would
I do such a move let's get out of pins
let's get out of pins before it's too
too late what an ugly position okay
Bishop here let's trade get that guy out
of there Queen d2 comes with the threat
now I'm on the Queen and the a pond and
the a pond there on my sea pond there on
my sea pond sea pond sea pond
let's guard the sea pond I like my
bishop I'm on the a pond undermine it
chase that Queen away flight squared H
3G 4 is maybe pushing it I can recapture
I'm on the Queen that wouldn't be a good
idea oh they're at my queen ok what do
we do get the king towards the center
I'm on their pond again and I could take
that I could take this actually if rook
to b8 I take this guy ok I'm gonna take
it he's a past pond he's ugly he's one
of the ugly guys but I'm gonna go with
that Forks get my king towards the
center rook to c8 loses a piece lose the
rook okay they sidestep that I'm gonna
guard why okay get my king up King up
I'm watching over b8 I'm watching over
b8 and your help out King do something
do something fast there we go there we
go Oh close the forks and stuff what
next is the night close to trap the
night is close to trapped uh-oh trade
this is a good one
get the rooks off they're down on time
buddy got no time back to tournament 108
151 28 108 108 here we go less than okay
I just dropped back now other people are
winning too it's very tight up there I
want
a half a granola bar or 1/4 granola bar
something that could you know help out
with granola bars here we go here we go
you know what's coming you know what's
coming
start stiff and then there's a P ends
with the knee 93 96 queenside castle
coming up H - how do they defend dark
square weakness oh I really want to just
smash that open I really really did okay
that diagonal is opened maybe they're
gonna go in for a fork it's not a good
idea it's not a good idea
uh-oh bad idea checks checks and then
the queen is dead with check and then I
get the pod okay that was a killer that
was a killer take this pawn get my
Knight to g4 or Bishop to f4 get rid of
the dark square bishop and then do some
damage against the king quickly
hopefully let's push push again f5 or
efore actually let's get this in
although my bishops hit oh that's a
little bit scary this move I want to get
this move in really soon really soon
incoming Fork incoming fork right here
efore efore winning a piece width check
I don't do that back to Charlie yes
that's a quick resigner 170 148 130 128
128 6 and change okay here we go
man just one loss and still it's I just
dropped a pond okay they didn't they
didn't take the pun oh hang on I still
want thoughts of you know you know you
know darks where weaknesses
okay build my Center and get my knight
over in this direction and I'm gonna
play okay let's go push I'm gonna back
up and then get in G for now okay let's
just do this even if it's wrong I'm
gonna do that okay if they take I can
push that's a killer diagonal it's a
killer diagonal for me to have control
over a four a five next a four a five
week in the dark squares some more open
up okay I'm on the night resign come on
you know you want to resign the Queen
back it ups to keep it in a pin Knight
g4 go over here whoa trade Queens that
Queen has no business being there what's
she doing no business no business get
out of there you're gonna cash in they
take that I'm on the Queen I can oh they
took with the Queen first that must have
been a mouse slip right here with check
pins pins and then when looking for me
very soon very soon
bone bone check and then mate back to
tournament 148 170 160 at 140 at 148
it's gonna come down to the wire wow wow
for a change
Florin change are we gonna can i get
maybe a quick resign it to propel me up
there come on somebody out there wants
to resign quick somebody wants to resign
click I have a feeling that wants to
happen something something like that is
gonna happen right let me just try that
is it gonna work we're gonna see about
it
just take that Bishop take him take him
he's free
he's a free bishop you know he's free
okay now he's much he's definitely free
look at how much this has simplified
he's got to be free at this point
undermine this position this pond the
queenside
94 swing my queen over laterally on the
h-file if that bishops ever taken push
this night around push them around and
now get my rook to okay now I'm gonna
take because now the structures ruined
and then get my queen over here can I
clean do something soon let's do this
I'm on f3 push the knight around I want
to stop Knight f5 okay and now discover
checks there might be more than one
discovered check available where does
the King go uh-oh looking for me and two
one maybe two or one for me how to
defend how to defend matin - so what do
we got
sewing tick tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick mate back to tournament 168
188 170 168 two minutes and 20 seconds
this guy again come on come on this is
like maybe the last game can I get a
third what do we got what do we got what
do we got what do we got now I want to
get this in and then weasel my knight
around and support my Center are they
gonna release the tension okay let's
watch over b4 in case of CD okay Knight
there I'm gonna back my bishop up they
did this again they're doing this again
I don't know that this is a good idea f5
is a killer or Knight to Knight to g5
targeting f7 this is a one position time
though time time a killer fork I'm on it
again check but I'm in a pin if I do
that rip to f7 maybe okay this is this
is definitely crumbling now it's
definitely crumbling check I'm on the
clean next
and where does that Queen go she's
running out of squares on the bishop pom
push and then dark squares oh I missed
that pin
okay pod push discovered check let's
back it up pine push discover check
still it's just advance it Bishop to d6
okay I'm gonna take these my king is
more vulnerable but hopefully it'll be
alright
uh-oh g2 g2 is a bit scary let's cover
that take okay now if that Knight moves
there's trouble for them check that's oh
that's me oh I needed that one 9188 45
seconds can I actually win can I
actually win oh here we go
I might know what do we got what do we
got what do we got that bishops trapped
there's not gonna be a quick resign is
there there's no way my opponent
wouldn't resign so quick
would they no way no way get rid of that
um light square bishop um on that night
I could have just taken right here I'm
on the night and the bishop pin this guy
and then do what take this Oh what do we
got what do we got third I'll take it
I'll take a couple crowds oh man
somebody I guess beat me out that second
spot right at the end that was tight
that was tight
oh man what a rough tournament oh man
that was tight that was tight 208 190
188 I was in victory lane victory lane
is top three Wow that was nuts
Joseph 208 J Oak 191 88 I ended up
getting so he actually didn't have a
squeaky-clean performance so I guess
there was maybe a draw from what he's
saying right there Wow
good games nuts